Speaker 1: Let's go next to Steph from Glasgow.
Speaker 6: Oh, wow.
Welcome.
Hi, but I just wanted to say as a person,
not from America,
Speaker 1: really, I couldn't tell from your
accent.
I thought you were from Texas, you know?
Speaker 6: Oh, well.
Well, and I just find the whole gun culture
thing insane.
Yeah, it's it baffles me.
And I've actually just been saying to myself
earlier, like, if you were claiming self-defense,
would you not of like, here?
You would just kick the person and make them
leave you alone?
Like what it?
What's the automatic reaction to it?
Point a gun and shoot somebody baffles me.
Speaker 1: This is exactly what I'm talking
about when I'm saying, you know, we're looking
at these videos of 20 people walking around
with long guns and all of this insanity.
And we're trying to focus in on this narrow
question of like, was Rittenhouse justified
in shooting the people that he shot?
Much of the world is having exactly your reaction,
which is how is even the context remotely
considered acceptable in any way at all that
this is even a thing that happens?
It.
Speaker 6: Yeah, it's just it's just a totally
different culture, and it's scary because
he's just a kid as well.
It's.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: It's now are people are people
in Scotland talking about this case at all?
Speaker 6: And I know from what I've seen
nothing on the news about it, really.
OK.
And nobody that I talked to really as mentioned,
either.
So I don't think it's the like thing, to be
honest, but I follow American politics more
than people that I know so and like American
crime and stuff.
So.
And yeah, most people are less interested
in it.
Got it.
Speaker 1: Got it.
Hey, quick question, are you familiar with
a with?
Now I don't even remember what they're called.
What do you guys call sodas?
You call them busies fizzy something.
Speaker 6: And I would say fizzy juice busy.
Speaker 1: Are you saying fizzy or fuzzy
Speaker 6: as he exercise?
Oh, I see.
Speaker 1: Oh, a fizzy juice.
Got it, OK?
And so is Sprite a fizzy juice?
What is it?
It's a type of fizzy juice.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I got it.
It's fizzy drinks like we also use just like
names like I would just say all our Diet Coke
or whatever.
So we just use it in what fizzy juices like
are an umbrella term.
Speaker 1: It's your category.
It's a category like some people would say,
this is soda.
This is pop.
This is a fizzy juice.
Speaker 6: Yes.
Got it.
As you just got.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: OK, well, you really set it all.
I can't.
I can't think of anything else to mention
at this point.
Speaker 6: And thank you for taking my call.
I'm still nervous, I don't know if you can
tell,
Speaker 1: I can't tell at all.
You did great.
Speaker 6: Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you so much for
the call.
Nobody's all right, there we go, Steve, from
Glasgow.
Very, very powerful testimony.
Let's go next to Isaiah from Arkadelphia.
Isaiah, you're on the air.
Isaiah from Arkadelphia, you're on the air.
I hear you're completely digitally modulated,
I couldn't understand a word of that.
Speaker 2: Oh, oh, boy.
Speaker 1: And you're not.
Are you a robot or is that just a voice distortion?
Speaker 2: No, I'm not quitting.
You're not a robot.
Oh boy,
Speaker 1: oh dear God.
All right.
Unfortunately, I am going to have to let you
go.
Just nobody can hear what's going on there.
It was interesting, but nobody could hear
it.
Let's try Amir from Washington, D.C., Amir.
It is your turn.
Speaker 2: Oh, God.